Oh, my God, please welcome my mom
from "E.T." Dee Wallace.
(audience applauding)
You look so good.
(audience applauding and cheering)
How are you?
Oh, my God.
First of all, your kimono is everything
and I love it so much.
Thank you.
And I'm just so happy to see you.
You know, you gave me that book,
I remember it so well, "The Velveteen Rabbit."
Yes.
And I literally love that book
and you're so associated with it
and I think about it all the time.
Oh.
You're so ever present with me in that book
and just all of the things, how have you been?
I've been awesome.
I've been great.
Still working doing a lot of films
and I have a whole healing practice, as you know
where I teach people about self love.
Oh, wow, I should come by.
(audience applauding)
Yes, thank you, yeah.
It's about to be the 40th anniversary of "E.T."
I mean, literally it's happening.
Can you believe it?
Again.
You look so hot.
Look at us.
That was the first day on the set
and I'm sitting in this really high director's chair
and Drew comes up to me and she says,
"Hi, I'm going to sit on your lap now."
(Drew laughs)
And I said, "Well, come on up Drew."
I mean, I knew you were gonna be
a director, producer back then.
Really?
Oh, for sure.
Are you gonna watch the movie
for the 40th anniversary-
Of course.
And have a little nostalgia reminisce?
We're all gonna be there, aren't we?
I remember when you showed up in like Halloween
and you were, you were sexy.
We were all like, "Wow, Mom's sexy."
(Dee laughs)
You had that little cat outfit on.
I still fit it in, too.
Oh, I bet you do.
(audience applauding)
You are giving me gold.
And is it true that you saw Steve Spielberg jump
on top of an "E.T." costume that was on fire,
did that happen?
Yeah, you don't remember that,
no, I don't think,
you weren't on the set.
Something happened and one of
the costumes caught on fire one day
and everybody froze.
They went huh, and Steven went huah!
That's so Steven.
Yeah, just-
Here's a fun fact.
Steven, my daughter, Frankie,
she's obsessed with him and it's so cute
and he'll send her videos
and the other day she asked him,
like we found out that Jaws' nickname was Bruce.
Oh, you didn't know that?
I didn't and guess what, Bruce was his lawyer.
How awesome is that.
I think it's pretty apropos.
Exactly, it's synonymous with the profession.
Well, I really, from what I remember
"E.T." was kept alive on set at all times.
I mean, I would go have lunch with "E.T." a lot.
I saw the wires, I knew the deal.
I was like-
Oh, do not believe that for a moment.
But I-
Oh, do not, no, Drew Barrymore.
We found you one day
and they would put "E.T." in a corner
when he wasn't working.
And we found Drew and she's
over there just talking to him
and from that time on,
Steven had two guys on "E.T." at all times
so that any time you went over to talk to him,
his eyes could work and his head
could go up and down
and he could respond to you.
I gotta tell you this story.
Do you remember filming "E.T.'s" death scene?
Oh, God, yes.
And do you remember me coming over
to pick you up to do it?
Yes, yes.
And Steven got me to cry.
Oh, no.
Okay.
So this is how it went down.
Being the mother that I am with all the kids
that I work with,
you were on a adjoining sound stage
and I went over and I said,
"Okay, Drew, now we're gonna go shoot
the scene where E.T.'s dying,
but you know he's not really dying, sweetheart.
He's acting just like we are, okay?"
And you looked at me and you said,
"I know Dee, do you think I'm stupid?"
(audience laughing)
So I picked you up,
we walked into the set.
You took one look at E.T. and went (crying),
"Ah, he's dying, Dee, he's dying."
(audience applauding)
You were always so kind to me.
I'm so thrilled that you would come here today
and grace us with your presence
and tell us these stories
and this is just such a fortunate moment for myself.
Thank you everybody who's like bearing witness to it.
Dee Wallace.
Dee is an author and you can pick up her book,
"Born, Giving Birth to a New You,"
which is now available.
(upbeat music)